während sich die Ampel also um AKWs soft
heute geht's weiter ist Deutschland in
Sorge vor dem krisenwinter wie kommen
wir durch die kalte Jahreszeit wo kann
ich noch sparen und was kann ich mir
eigentlich noch leisten ja die Sorgen
der deutschen am letzten Wochenende
blieben sie zumindest von den Grünen
ungehört die haben nämlich gefeiert
bei den Grünen im Partypeople der
Regierung nach der Sitzung ist vor dem
Karte die Stimmung ausgelassen und alle
tanzen ohne Maske
doch wenige Stunden vorher ein
klassischer Parteitag das Sehen und
Gesehen werden Hände schütteln das Reden
über sich selbst wir sind die
nachherpartei Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Applaus keine großartigen Änderung
nichts weltbewegendes und irgendwie
wenig Spaß und trotzdem ein grüner
Partei da ganz entgegen der eigenen
Parteilinie denn immer wieder fällt auf
die Grünen fordern Dinge die sie selbst
nicht einhalten Beispiel eins
Waffenlieferung Sicherheit Frieden
Abrüstung heißt es im parteipapier
direkt im zweiten Absatz wir lehnen
Waffenlieferung in kriegs- und
Krisengebiete ab und was macht die
ko-chefin der Grünen Ricarda lang sie
fordert die schnellere Waffenlieferung
in die Ukraine ich bin überzeugt dass
wir mehr Waffen liefern müssen dass wir
schneller werden müssen die Zeit der
Zögerlichkeit ist vorbei Beispiel zwei
maskenpflich
t teiltags alle 800 Delegierte müssen
Maske tragen so will es die
grünenführung und nach der Arbeit Party
tanzen ohne Maske nicht das erste Mal
das für die Grünen andere Gesetze gelten
auch auf dem Oktoberfest zeigen sich
Ricarda lang und Claudia Roth vergnügt
ohne Maske es wäre ja alles okay so
würde diese Freiheit auch für jeden
anderen Menschen im Land gelten zum
Beispiel auch beim Bahnfahren Beispiel 3
Diskriminierung zurück zum Parteitag auf
der Party läuft der Song jump around von
House of Pain
dort heißt es unter anderem if your girl
steps ab einem smaking the whole das so
viel bedeutet wie wenn dein Mädchen
aufsteht schlage ich die [ __ ] das Lied
ist sexistisch polizeifeindlich und
gewaltverherrlichen Grünen Chef Omid
Nuri pur selbst ist es der genau diesen
Song aufliegt vor dem DJ Bult steht und
die Menge anheizt und das bei einer
Partei die für Gender gerechte Sprache
gleich mächtige und Toleranz stehen will
die Grünen fassen ihre Arbeit nach den
Parteitag zufrieden so zusammen wir sind
die macherpartei Bündnis 90 die Grünen
die momentan ein bisschen viele Fehler
machen
[Musik]